(zooming)
(boom)
- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is BelieveIn.
I believe in people more than
they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is that
if you believe in yourself as much
as I believe in you, you'll
be able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
nine surprising facts
about Will Smith.
(slow techno music)
(ding)
Fact number one, he believes
he can become president
of the United States if he wanted to.
- A few months ago I
said that I believe that,
(Jonathan laughs)
if I chose to,
I could be the president
of the United States.
And I think, as I've had a
chance to intellectualize
why I said that,
- Yeah.
- and I think that there's
a certain delusional quality
that all successful people have to have.
You have to believe
that something different
than what has happened for
the last 50 million years
- Yeah, yeah right.
- of history,
you have to believe that
something different can happen.
And I say it to my friends all the time
and we laugh about it.
I truly, honestly, as I
sit before you right now,
as honestly as I can say it to you,
I truly believe that I could
be the president if I wanted to.
And as bizarre as that may sound
- Yeah.
- to people that
have traveled the path before me,
and to people who actually
know how difficult it is,
foolish Will Smith honestly believes it.
(ding)
- Fact number two, he knows how
to solve the Rubik's Cube really quickly.
(Will muttering)
- [Woman] Two minutes.
- [Will] Okay, what do we
got, what do we got, okay.
- [Woman] Almost, almost.
(Will muttering)
(Woman muttering)
- [Woman] One minute left.
- Uh, I'm not ready.
(laughing)
- [Woman] You said two minutes. (laughs)
- [Will] Alright, umm.
- [Woman] Are you getting it?
Maybe you pretend to be.
- No, no, I got it, it
just takes a minute.
It just takes a minute.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- [Man] No, it's fine, it's fine.
- [Woman] That's the whole problem with
the Rubik's Cube.
- No, it's fine, it's fine.
(Will muttering)
- Oh!
- Whoa, whoa, whoa!
- [Man] Oh.
- [Woman] Whoa, we've got something there.
Man!
- Almost.
(audience exclaiming)
- Yes!
- Whoa!
(audience cheering)
(Will laughing)
- There you go, you kids
were runnin' for real,
I had you runnin' for real.
(ding)
- Fact number three, he's part owner
of the Philadelphia 76ers basketball team.
- There is nothing like,
in all of entertainment,
than to walk into the building
when it's announced
that you're a part owner
of your hometown basketball team.
- I can't even imagine.
- Like,
that is ridiculous.
I mean, if the team
doesn't win it sucks later.
- Yeah, right, right. (laughs)
- Right.
(audience laughing)
- But at first initial,
it's like fantastic.
It's like, yeah Will!
(Jonathan laughing)
(ding)
Fact number four,
he was the first hip hop artist
to be nominated for an Academy Award.
(audience laughing)
- And were you nominated for
an Academy Award?
- Nominated for an Oscar, yep.
- [Jonathan] What a great moment.
- Best Actor.
- I read somewhere that you can't,
'cause you lost it to Denzel
Washington, didn't you?
- Well now, you don't
lose, see, you just...
- Well, you didn't win it, did you?
(audience laughing)
- You can pretty it up
however you want Will.
- Okay.
- Unless you take it all
- You don't lose
- You didn't win it.
- You don't lose an Oscar once you're,
I'm still the Academy Award nominee,
- Yes.
- Will Smith.
We're all winners.
- Yes.
No, no, no you're not.
(audience laughing)
- That's what they say at the Oscar lunch!
It says it over, it says,
you're all already winners.
- Okay, that's good.
- You weren't there Jonathan!
(audience laughs)
- No.
So Will, which of your
fellow winners
(Will laughing)
got to take the actual
award home that year?
- Denzel took it that year,
Denzel took it that year.
- And that was for?
Which one was that for?
- It was Training Day.
- Great film.
- Yes, no, fantastic film.
- First of all, great film.
But I read somewhere that you weren't,
you kind of, I don't know whether you said
you didn't feel ready, or same time,
maybe you thought this
wasn't your time yet.
- When you can get nominated,
you get invited to the party, it's huge.
- Yeah, big time.
- Ya know.
I can always tell when things aren't right
for me in my life at that time,
I didn't feel like that was the time.
You know, but for Pursuit of Happiness,
I actually felt like that was the time
and I still didn't win.
(Jonathan laughing)
(audience laughing)
- I was like, hey it's my time!
Wait, hold on, that
other boy took my thing.
(Jonathan laughing)
(audience laughing)
- He didn't win it, though.
- Well, we were all
winners once we got there.
- You're a double-winner!
(Will laughing)
- You just don't have one yet.
- You know, but I'm telling you,
it really is one of those awards,
it's so, it's like the show is so huge,
the concept of it is so huge,
it's wonderful to be
invited to the big dance.
(ding)
- Fact number five,
he first met his wife-to-be,
Jada Pinkett Smith, when she auditioned
to be his girlfriend on The
Fresh Prince of Bel Air.
- You mentioned Will, who
everybody knows who Will Smith is,
but I heard you auditioned
for Fresh Prince, too.
- I did.
(audience laughing)
- As his girlfriend.
- I did.
I auditioned as his girlfriend.
I'll never forget.
(host laughing)
(audience laughing)
You know, he was, it's funny
because he was there.
And that must've been his thing.
You know, comin' to the casting calls,
to see what
(host laughing)
you know, young girls
were comin' up in there.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So he's sittin' out in the hallway.
(host laughing)
So I walk in and, you
know the casting director,
she looks at me and she says,
you know I'm doin' my lines,
and she said, you know what?
You're just too short for Will,
but thank you for coming in.
And I was like, oh alright.
(host laughing)
(audience laughing)
Alright, cool.
So I walked out you know,
and Will was like, hey shorty,
let me talk to you, I was like.
(host laughing)
(audience laughing)
Ain't nothin' for us to talk about, homie.
She already said you ain't got
a role for me, keep steppin'.
(host laughing)
(audience laughing)
And then, over the years, you know,
I did A Different World,
and then I did a couple movies,
and then he want to come, you know,
fourth season, fifth season, asking me
to be his girlfriend again.
(host laughing)
You know, he came down to Winston-Salem
while I was doin' a movie called Inkwell.
- Oh yeah.
- And he was like, you know,
will you come and be a serious
regular on Fresh Prince?
And at that time, I was like,
I'm not tryin' to do television right now.
(host laughing)
And I'm glad that I said no
'cause we probably
wouldn't be married now.
(ding)
- Fact number six,
the film he most regrets making
is Wild Wild West.
It's too bad, I really like that movie.
- Now have you failed in the
last five years, ten years?
Do you consider anything
you've done a failure?
- Yes, oh absolutely.
- [Host] Like what?
- Certain things, um...
- [Host] Because a movie
didn't gross as much,
is that failure?
- No, actually the converse,
with Wild Wild West.
- Yeah.
- It felt like a failure
because the film wasn't great.
- Right.
- Ya know?
But it did 225 million.
- Yeah, and you know,
- Ya know?
- Yeah and you know what
gets said about that?
- And I was like, ah.
- They said,
that's because of Will
Smith, it's not because...
- But I was like, oh it hurts so bad.
(host laughing)
You know,
it felt like I got what I wanted
out of the deal, but my fans
didn't get their half of the deal.
(ding)
- Fact number seven,
he's the first rapper
to win a Grammy award.
- And I kind of forget sometimes,
'cause I think of you as a movie star,
a movie actor first and foremost.
I forget of course, this
huge career beforehand,
this big successful career as a rapper.
- Yep!
- And you were the first
rap act, I believe,
to win the Grammy.
- Yep, ever win a Grammy.
- Wow, wow.
- 1988 that's a long time ago.
- No one can ever take that away.
(audience cheering)
(Will laughing)
- [Jonathan] That's it, the
only time it's going to be done.
(ding)
- Fact number eight,
he speaks fluent Spanish.
- I'm fluent in Spanish.
(speaks in Spanish)
(audience laughs)
I'm fluent in French.
(speaks in French)
(audience laughs)
I'm fluent in Japanese.
(speaks Japanese)
(audience laughs)
- Whaddya think?
- Let's say Spanish.
- Mmm, that would be correct.
(contestants and audience cheering)
- Will, (speaks Spanish) After Earth?
- Oh okay, (speaks Spanish) to survive.
- (speaks Spanish)
- (speaks Spanish) (laughs)
(ding)
- And fact number nine,
he was chosen by People magazine
as one of the fifty most
beautiful people in the world.
- When I go to theaters
where my movies come out
and I sit in the back and I try to see
how people are reacting,
and there a scene in Bad Boys
when I was running with my shirt open,
it was the first time in my life ever,
I heard a woman go, mmm.
(audience laughing)
(Will laughs)
- Right there.
- Yeah.
And I was like, I didn't know what to do.
I was like, what was that Miss?
(audience laughing)
But it really is a strange
thing to be considered,
Like when I think sexy, I look at Denzel
and I was like, now that's a sexy man.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- But I just never thought of myself
in that way.
- Yeah.
- So it's fun!
- So thank you guy so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know which of the facts
were new to you, were a surprise to you.
Do you hope Will Smith one
day runs for president?
I'd love to get your thoughts.
Leave it down in the Comments below.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see ya soon.
(zooming)
(boom)